is a famous example of you know you
can't get much more compressed than this
and it's a very lovely example so
Hemingway's six word novel
Jonathan can you provide insights into
the structure of a short story and how
it differs from other forms of
Storytelling such as novels or novellas
sure
um
well one thing that I think is somewhat
different about a short story versus
longer forms
is I think that the writer has to start
making choices
a little bit earlier on
in terms of
what the story is going to be about I
think I think with a longer work
you have a little more time to sort of
set things out at the beginning
um to to handle the setting to you know
do some history of a town like these
kinds of things you have a little more
flexibility since you have a little bit
more space you can
you can you can you can do those kinds
of things whereas with a short story as
we saw when I showed you the the Mona
Simpson the Lori Moore and the Ernest
Hemingway stories each of those stories
gets to be what it is like and what it's
going to become very quickly like
dramatic action you know significant
internal
thought
uh dialogue you know moving right into
what is important
what is significant
right because there's there's almost
like a relationship between the reader
and the writer and the reader is saying
okay read writer I will pay close
attention to your story and in return I
expect you to only tell me what is
important and what is essential and what
is Meaningful and if you start straying
too far from that and showing me stuff
that's not that important
I'm going to lose faith in you and I may
quit reading your story
so with a short story there's just no
time to waste I mean first paragraphs
are enormously important
um and that's when you're beginning to
create the arena of where the action is
going to take place and how it's going
to take place
um you know for example
is this during covet times like that's a
very important part of the Laurie Moore
story so she establishes right away
these are the times that the characters
are living in and all of this kind of
information gets transmitted to us like
within 50 words you know a small number
of words
sure with the Mona Simpson character
forgive me I don't remember was it was
the gender reveal because I was no but
it is a female okay I'm picturing
someone that's maybe a middle class
upper middle class who doesn't need
these items but there is a thrill that
they get and and we've all heard of
people that have done this in the past
and and there's just something about the
fact that they're able to get away with
that that just it's like a drug to them
yeah
exactly
um
yeah and you got that without her
telling you that you know she she showed
you based on how the character uses
language you know that she may be from a
certain class background she may have us
be of a certain age she may have a
certain race ethnicity National
background I mean this is another thing
that stories need to accomplish very
quickly is this kind of information
because you're now starting to create
all of these mental images of who this
character is based on the way she uses
words the way she perceives the world
the way she thinks about herself the way
she thinks about uh the past I mean so
much gets transmitted
though in those ways yeah she doesn't
sit down and say reader I'm an upper
middle class girl from X place or you
know so on
it just gets transmitted through her use
of language sure yeah Jonathan how
should writers approach character
development in a short story considering
the limited time they have to explore
backgrounds and motivations yeah this is
an important question and I think every
short story writer asks him or herself
that question throughout
you know the time throughout the years
really because it's always important
um one thing that writers do and that I
I sometimes do as well is keep character
journals and character journals are they
can just be lists of qualities that the
character has you know things that the
character has done and it can also just
sort of be a timeline of important
events so what year was the character
born you know what year did they marry
um you know what were the significant
events when did the character leave home
whatever it is that's important in the
story to sort of keep track of when it
happened and when it happened in
relationship to other things is really
important in sort of in terms of of
keeping things really tight you know
compressed because you're trying to
choose
you know the the timeline of events that
are important events another way of
thinking about this question is
sometimes if I want a very sort of brief
thumbnail kind of description of what a
story is or even almost a definition of
what it is
I sometimes talk about stories as
mapping a process of meaningful change
so I think if there's no change in a
story readers might say well this didn't
go anywhere this didn't sort of pay off
um but I don't think you want to
Telegraph the changes in the character
either so I think one thing that you
have to decide when writing a short
story is like whatever event a is like
whatever sort of the most important
earliest event is
how does that event or line of dialogue
or whatever it is
how does it begin the process of change
that will ultimately be what the story
is about
and how do you
how do you do that and the answer is you
may need an entire draft to figure that
out you may not know that when you first
sit down to write the story but if
you're thinking in terms of the things
I've talked about already uh you know is
this believable is this motivated and is
this complex
um then I think eventually you'll arrive
at
you know the process of meaningful
change that the story
ends up mapping
how does the opening of a short story
differ from a longer form story
I personally really tend to respond to
stories
that have
urgency at the beginning
um like you don't know how urgent first
of all if you call a story The Killers
it already creates urgency because we're
starting to wonder who the killers are
who they're going to kill have they
already killed people you know the kinds
of high-stakes questions that we're
asking happen just from the title and
then from the first two sentences here
they come into the Lunch Counter here
they're sitting down now they're you
know not taking off their overcoats and
their gloves like
this is creating a sense of urgency and
the reader a sense of I have to know
what's going to happen next it's it's
firing those you know firing our
imagination and setting up the stakes
like you know is someone gonna get his
heart hurt or I mean whatever the stakes
of the story are life and death in the
case of that one you begin to set that
up at the beginning of a short story but
you can also do that with a longer form
story too I just think
you the the sense of urgency is
important but you can take perhaps a
little longer to articulate what that
urgency is
okay maybe you can help me uh Workshop
something just real quick so if if I was
going to come up with let's say a CEO
and
um this guy's almost superhuman and
maybe kind of just open it up with
he always got what he wanted
um what you know I I don't know I don't
have this fleshed out but just I'm I'm
painting a picture of someone who's
who's he's 10 steps ahead of everybody
else yeah and it's true he never nothing
he never touches failure and I think
that that he seems like this sort of
Superman right
um uh hearing the word no
was like a chess game to him I don't
know right or something yeah so I'm I'm
using little short bursts right to
describe this man yeah who's charismatic
but also Underneath It All a shark
they're used to they're very strategic
in how they play their cards right
well what I mean one way to approach
this story like that is to just put him
into action being a shark like instead
of explaining to the reader reader this
is what kind of person he is like show
him doing shark-like things like show
him taking advantage of people show him
feeling invulnerable like
I mean I think you know
fiction and short fiction in particular
convinces through the senses like if you
want a reader to
remember and be able to sensorily
experience a story you have to provide
sensory detail you know things that the
character sees
you know smells touches tastes and hears
and
once you're sort of engaging the senses
then the story can take up ideas a
little bit more but I think ultimately
it's you know
dramatic action dialogue
um some thought
are
are best to use when possible
and you know if explanation or summary
is helpful in certain parts of the story
then yeah use use that
um
but I I jump into action with especially
someone who's behaving the way he is I
mean that's a fascinating character
and also you know there's a part of me
that thinks well if he doesn't really
contemplate failure it would be
interesting to put him in a situation
where
he might actually fail and if he fails
there may be consequences that are going
to be difficult for him to deal with we
were just talking about sort of short
all fiction has to be compressed I mean
you know the all details have to be
significant artist selective and you
have to select details that are going to
add up to meaning in their in their in
the readers
experience but thinking of Hemingway and
how good he was at that particularly in
his stories from his 20s
um
he it's it's a it's a famous example of
you know you can't get much more
compressed than this and it's a very
lovely example so Hemingway's six word
novel
for sale
baby shoes never worn
no comment beyond that okay it's like
that that kind of speaks for itself yeah
because you think oh and then it takes
you down then you just wow yeah yeah
I mean you could write a novel